[Music]
ceremonial fly over in London and other
events in Europe marked this morning's
75th anniversary of Nazi Germany's
surrender other VE Day celebrations were
canceled due the due to the coronavirus
but a new book celebrates some of the
unsung heroes of America's World War two
effort Jan Crawford spoke to one of the
women who helped break down barriers by
taking to the sky girl more than 1,100
women Air Force Service Pilots or wasps
flew for the US military during World
War two transporting planes from the
factory and helping with target practice
so male pilots could fight overseas at a
time when they were viewed as anything
but equal yes they talked army talk and
they wear GI clothes that she still is
softer fairer sex
worried to death she's going to get her
hair wet 98 year-old Nell bright skipped
meals to afford flying lessons and was
ultimately accepted into the seventh
class of wasps you know you had the same
training as the man you were treated
like military officers but you were
considered civilians military rather
than allow them to join the military the
wasp experiment was disbanded before the
end of the war and largely forgotten for
decades because it was extraordinary
bright and others left the sky behind I
got married two kids it took more than
30 years in the help of prominent
Arizona senator Barry Goldwater toward
the wasps veteran status
thank you for your patriotism and
another 30 years before they were
awarded the Congressional Medal of Honor
for their service they just wanted to be
remembered for what they did
Katelyn Dec teaches history at Texas
Woman's University and in her new book
the women with silver wings she
describes the adversity these women had
to overcome both inside the military and
out they fought and fought and fought
and just kept doing what needed to be
done and that's the message that I hope
gets through is that perseverance if you
just sit back and let people tell you no
you're never gonna get to take off into
that blue sky out of the 1,800 wasps who
went through training there are only 32
still living but landok hopes her book
will keep their legacy alive they are
independent minded and they were
stubborn they wanted to fly those
airplanes and they wanted to serve their
country and so they did both and you
proved them wrong right right it took
nearly a lifetime for a new generation
to recognize the wasps for their role in
shaping history and bright said she's
still getting used to it the young come
up and say oh we can have done this how
does that make you feel when you hear
things like that
it takes a while for it to sink you and
I think but it makes us feel for CBS
this morning Jan Crawford Washington
Bravo and kudos to Nell bright 98 years
old sort of paving the way it makes me
so proud to be a girl I like it